hello good evening and welcome to
another edition of gadget lab podcasts
I'm Michael glory I am Mike Isaac and
today we have Christina showing us some
tiny cameras and we're also later we're
going to bring out a really cool
microscope amount that lets you take
pictures of things under a microscope
using your smartphone but first we have
some news so mike has some news for us
about the the fancy google phone there
in his hand I do this is the Samsung
Galaxy Nexus which you've been hearing
about for quite some time but google
debuted you know over a month ago and we
haven't seen it hit the stores it was
basically this is the new phone this is
the second coming of Android and you're
going to get it soon and then we heard
nothing right but then finally finally
today after what 6 rumored launches yeah
rumor after rumor that this phone is
actually going to launch it it has
finally come out available for verizon
in the US for three hundred dollars
which is kind of pricey but if you're
into books on contract on interior
believe that was my prediction for the
pricing that and you got it right but
nevermind but there was kind of a saga
though like behind the scenes with
getting this phone out you know Verizon
and Google kind of went head-to-head on
a basically Google's new wallet app
which is their their NFC based solution
to mobile payments that's like the near
field communication that's like if
you're the whole foods you want to pay
you just tap your phone against the cash
register right exactly they want they
want to make your phone like the new
Swiss Army knife right so you don't have
to have a wallet anymore you don't have
to have another phone I don't know what
else could you do the phone quit
occurred a credit card exactly yeah they
wanted to give everything so yeah so
it's better usage I don't have a phone
so so basically verizon wanted to keep
wallet off of this phone because the
phone companies are forming this joint
venture called Isis to institute their
own mobile payment solution at some
point but the funny thing is Isis is
still
it's sort of like fledgling stages they
don't have a product out they don't
really know what it was it's going to be
or at least we don't know what it's
going to be yet but google wallet is
already debuted right so this is the
second phone that has NFC on it you
expect this will be the big push into
google wallet with the nexus s before it
and we can't use it so so the reason the
phone was delayed is because verizon
didn't want to use google's automatic
payment system that is already up and
running yes a thousands of locations
nationwide yes they can replace it with
their own built by committee by all the
characters coming soon sometime in 2012
yes oh that's really smart that is
awesome customer service on verizon's
behalf really makes me want to buy the
phone right anyway if you want to decide
whether or not the phone is something
you want to purchase you can read Mike's
review this mikes review at why calm
right now it's live on the internet and
I believe he gave it an 8 out of 10 yeah
here's pretty um the big reason you
wanted of course besides the fact that
it's a hot new phone that everybody's
waiting for is that it runs Ice Cream
Sandwich the latest Android and it is
the purest version of ice cream sandwich
there's no skinning or anything it's
exactly how Google intended it yeah and
you liked it it's rad I really liked it
it's um it's probably the best operating
system that google has put out for
mobile today and the best phone that
it's been running on it's better than
the iphone that's the first question I
always just dance he can't shut up a
thought okay i did i've been playing
with an iphone I've been playing with
both phones and he's released a gram I
am RJ underscore eyes Jesus lovely
ladies I might Instagram I take good
shots okay let's go to Christina
speaking of taking shots she's going to
show us get my drunk little tiny cameras
and then she's committed during some
booze and then we come back and take a
look at the skylight scope now
hi I'm Christina Bonnington and today
I've got some teensy tiny miniature
cameras to show you they're perfect for
fitting inside a stocking first up we've
got the kodak easyshare mini it can take
pictures up to 10 megapixels and it's
got a 3x optical zoom it's got a two and
a half inch LCD viewfinder on the back
it's got a lot of the same features
you'd find in a larger point and shoot
but it's definitely not the same quality
it'll run you ninety dollars and if you
are looking for more quality and not
just the size you're better off going
with one of those larger canvas this is
that mr. digital clover soon he is a
Japanese import and he's super tiny fits
on a keychain you can slide this one
side out and up pops a viewfinder the
pictures it's supposed to take a kind of
lomo style you know those filters you
see on Instagram and hipstamatic with
the really over saturated colors it
doesn't quite do it that well but what
it does have is a cool video feature
that lets you take kind of 8-millimeter
style of video finally we have the Minox
classic mini digital camera it can take
pictures up to 5.1 megapixels and it's
styled after a leica m three it's got an
optical viewfinder on the top and it's
also got a two inch LCD viewfinder on
the back a lot of these knobs and things
are just for decoration but it you can
adjust the distance from point five
meters to one meter to infinity and all
this cool style you're gonna pay for it
it's a hundred eighty dollars don't know
if it's worth it or not maybe if you
have a nice little camera collection
those were some very tiny cameras here's
a way that you can take pictures with
your smartphone camera of very tiny
things don't say it this is the skylight
scope mount this is a prototype actually
this is a project that's being developed
by a couple of engineers actually a
designer from the medical industry and a
geologist in Northern California and it
is an all plastic mount and it's a
universal mount so it holds your
smartphone any smartphone that will fit
inside of it and all right phone android
iphone Windows Phone whatever you have
with a camera on the back cool you mount
it on to any scope with a cylindrical
eyepiece up to 1.75 inches so it fits on
any microscope it fits on most
telescopes and most spotting scopes so
birders and astronomers can use this to
perverts and peeping can be taking it to
the next level on the other you can add
filters to your weight spine sorry this
is yeah he's taken it off the rail I
mean basically it's it's a it's a it's a
mount for educational purposes and for
healthcare and for basically geeks who
like to look at small things on on
slides so we were playing around with
this morning we took some really awesome
pictures of and scary essence yeah
really cool close-ups advanced also
plants we had a couple of flowers pants
pants we looked at some five fan tease
we looked at some rice seasoning it's
just amazing like normal everyday
household objects become really awesome
when you look at them under the skylight
mount it's a sixty-dollar item and right
now you can pre-order it on Kickstarter
the team actually met their funding this
week but there's still another two weeks
to buy in and if you pledge sixty
dollars you can get amount for your for
yourself and every five that are
purchased they're going to give one way
they're going to give them either to an
educational organization or they're
going to get
to a medical organization for research
another cool application not just for
taking pictures and tweeting them is
that you can actually set up a skype
session or a FaceTime session we also
did this this morning which is really
cool so somebody mounts their phone on
here and then initiates FaceTime and
then somewhere else in the world
somebody can look at their phone or on
their computer if it's skype and see
what you're looking at through the
microscope or through the telescope so
scientists teleconferencing across the
load yeah origin or you know just
friends hanging out looking at stuff
right now I got my hands yeah you can
you can help people that you help people
identify pests in their gardens huh
there's all kinds of cool applications
this an uncle that could help me there
probably yeah well busy have skype I
don't know if he knows how to figure
that out there's is it when is it coming
out as it's coming out next year so this
is like I said this is a prototype this
is fabricated it's entirely plastic it's
just a few simple pieces very easy to
mount it comes with a couple of rings
little sizing rings that you can use to
fit around any eyepiece and it will even
fit around I pieces that have
obstructions on them so if you have like
a focus ring or some sort of you know
screw mount in there it clamps right
around it the client is very simple kids
can operate it people shaking hands can
operate it it's really cool and if
you're if you get one and you're
tweeting pictures or instagramming
pictures use the hashtag skylight scope
all one word that's the new hashtag that
the founders have told us they want to
start using that's pretty cool we're
really excited about this when it
finally launches will let you know on
gadget lab and you can find out more by
going to skylight scope calm and you can
buy into the kickstarter funding project
on your website on the kickstarter
website there's a link on their website
to buy in sweet so that's all we have
for the gadget lab this week we'll be
back next week to show you a fancy
camera and probably another fancy phone
or two and we will have more news for
you of course so until then we'll see
you later
you